So now I'd like to
introduce today's speakers.
Today's featured speakers
are Ron Fedkiw and Gordon Wetzstein.
Ron Fedkiw is a professor of
Computer Science at Stanford University.
He received his PhD in
Mathematics from UCLA.
And his post-doctoral studies
were at UCLA in mathematics and
at Caltech in aeronautics
before joining Stanford.
He was awarded an Academy Award from
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences twice, the National Academy of
Science Award for Initiatives in Research,
a Packard Foundation fellowship,
Presidential Early Career Award for
Scientists and Engineers,
along with several other awards.
He is currently on the editorial board of
the Journal of Computational Physics and
he participates in the reviewing
process of a number of journals and
funding agencies.
He has published about 120 research
papers in computational physics,
computer graphics and vision,
as well as a book on level set methods.
For the past 17 years, he has been
a consultant with Industria Light + Magic.
He received screen credits for movies such
as Terminator 3, Star Wars Episode 3,
Poseidon, Evan Almighty, and
most recently on Kong Skull Island.
Gordon Wetzstein is an Assistant Professor
of Electrical Engineering and by courtesy,
of Computer Science,
at Stanford University.
He's a leader of
the Stanford Computational Imaging Lab,
an interdisciplinary research group
focused on advancing imaging,
microscopy and display systems.
At the intersection of computer graphics,
machine vision optics,
scientific computing and perception,
Professor Wetzstein's research has a wide
range of applications in next generation
consumer electronics, scientific imaging,
human computer interaction,
remote sensing and many other areas.
He received a PhD in computer science from
the University of British Columbia and
graduated with honors from the Bauhaus
in Weimar, Germany before that.
He was won the Alain Fournier
PhD Dissertation annual award,
is the recipient of
an NSF CAREER award and
has won Best Papers at the International
Conference on Computational Photography,
as well as the Laval Virtual award.
So both of them are quite accomplished.
And I should also mention that they
are co-academic directors of our
new visual computing graduate certificate
which I will talk more about after
their presentation.
So now I'd like to first turn
the floor over to Gordon for
the first part of the presentation.
>> Thank you so much for
the introduction, Stephanie.
Time for visual computing, because there's
a lot of dynamics in both computer
graphics, computer vision, but also in the
[INAUDIBLE] perception in virtual reality.
So what we'd like to do today is walk
you through some of these topics so
you get an overview of what
visual computing is all about.
So Stephanie already introduced this, but
I pulled up this nice photo of Ron where
he received a technical achievement award.
And sorry about that, but
it was really a great achievement and
he's done a lot of groundbreaking
work in simulation and
visual effects and is now working
on machine learning as well.
I work more on the imaging side,
I also work on displays,
computer vision and
more recently on virtual reality as well.
So you may wonder what computational
imaging is all about and
all these topics are about.
So I just wanna walk you
through some of these and
show you some of the top
trends in these topics.
The computational imaging is usually
this idea of co-designing the optics,
the sensors, and
the algorithms for camera.
And traditionally cameras have been
designed by designing the optics forming
an image on a digital sensor or in a film
play and then just looking at the image.
But with the rise of computational power,
we can now co-design these things so
that the computer can understand the image
and extract meaningful information.
So what does it mean in practice?
In practice that means the camera today
doesn't work similar to what a camera did
a couple of hundred years ago,
even though it looks the same.
We now capture multiple images
with different exposures
every time that we hit the button, and
that's called high dynamic range imaging.
The modes of your cellphone
cameras will actually capture
different images all at once.
The processor on the phone will
then compute a single image
that combines the most useful
information from all of these images.
And that's pretty much in standard mode.
We can also think about super resolution,
so trying to resolve features in an image
that are not visible in the resolution
offered by the detector.
And there are many other
imaging modalities,
like sending the depth of fields,
capturing light fields,
and doing more exotic imaging
modalities like compression imaging.
So this all sounds great, and
how does that translate into practice?
Well, we've seen a couple of startup
companies coming out of Stanford and
also here in the Silicon Valley,
such as Lytro which built the consumer
electronics version of the electrocamera
that you can buy in the store now.
This camera allows you to do
things like post-capture refocus.
So you can take a picture and
if you got the focus wrong,
you can actually change it after the fact.
This camera also allows you to
extract depth information of a scene,
which is increasingly important for
things like autonomous driving,
consumer electronics, gaming,
and other applications.
Another consumer electronics
startup company,
just down the street here from Stanford,
is called Light.
Light has started to release
a camera that they call l16.
It has 16 different
cellphone camera modules.
You can see that here in the middle, and
they all have different focal lengths,
different properties, and they can all
snap a single picture of a scene and
then the computer will actually
figure out how to merge all of these
images into getting a really
wide field of view,
super high resolution image with
unprecedented image quality.
Light cameras aren't just meant for
consumer electronics.
They also enable new experiences,
for example, in virtual reality.
On the right you can see
Facebook's new 360 camera,
captures images in the 360
degrees sphere and can then
process these to fuse them together into
a seamless virtual reality experience.
So this also ties in back to enabling new
types of experiences with these imaging
systems, for example, in virtual reality.
So it turns out that the similar idea
can also be applied to displays.
This code design of algorithms and
unconventional optical systems
together with focusing on understanding
human beyond the visual system.
And a couple of research ideas that people
have been working on are high dynamic
range displays, super resolution displays,
new types of projectors or displays.
And of course, we all are also interested
in developing the next generation of
head mounted displays for AR and VR.
So I wanna talk about one of these
technologies a little bit more,
which has already migrated into
the consumer electronics world,
and that's high dynamic range displays.
So when I did my PhD about ten years ago,
that was a really nice research project
with a couple of papers,
things that you'd learn in a course.
But now you can actually buy
a television at Best Buy or
anywhere else that has that
technology integrated.
And every company has a different name for
it.
For example,
local dimming is what Samsung calls it.
And the basic idea is that you can
modulate the backlight of the television,
the LEDs that are actually
inside the television
together with the LCD that
is usually being used
to create a contrast that is much higher
that what you get with a normal display.
So that creates a much more
lifelike experience, and
much better user experience overall, okay.
So the basic idea between behind
computational imaging, for
me it's this bridge between optics and
modern signal processing optimization.
So we mostly work with geometric optics so
we think about light as a wave
travelling in straight lines in space.
My research group also does a lot
of work on using wave optics and
more complicated optical models
that are more physically accurate.
But for the most part in
computer vision and imaging,
it's good enough to think
about light as waves.
And then use modern techniques in
optimization, deep learning, machine
learning and so on to design new kinds
of devices such as cameras and this bot.
And these have applications in so
many different domains.
Every one of you probably has a whole
bunch of cameras already in your pocket.
Cuz your cellphone likely
has at least two of them.
But we also think about new and
emerging depth cameras for
consumer electronic applications,
or cameras on drones.
We can think about surveillance,
medical imaging.
Cameras are in space, they're being used
for biomedical applications in microscopy.
And they're being used, of course,
also for emerging autonomous vehicles or
self-driving cars, where the computer has
to make the decision of what to do next.
So, designing the sensors for these
kinds of systems is absolutely critical.
So now I'd like to think about
computer vision a little bit more and
how it's different from imaging.
Imaging is very close to the hardware.
We design algorithms and hardware
together, but at a very low level.
Computer vision is more concerned
with inferring high level
information of the scene.
Such as, you give me a couple
of images of your living room.
And the algorithm can figure out
what the 3D shape, and the texture,
and the colors are.
So that we can use that in, for example,
in an online program where we can
place new furnitures in your room.
And you can try out different
arrangements of your room.
You can order furniture
from IKEA online and
place them directly into your living room.
At the same time these techniques are also
useful for autonomous driving, for
robotic vision, and for
many different other fields.
But in general computer vision is
concerned with high level decision making,
or inference on data that
is captured with camera.
So another topic that comes up in computer
vision quite a lot is scene understanding.
So given an image, what's going on?
So if we look at the upper left image
here, this is a picture taken from a car.
The car wants to understand
where the lanes are.
It wants to understand where other
cars are, how fast they are driving.
On the lower left we see
an example of segmentation.
We wanna understand,
is it a pedestrian we're looking at?
Is it a bicyclist?
Is it a driver?
Is it a building?
Is it a dynamic part of the scene?
And so on.
So segmentation, object tracking,
object understanding and recognition,
these are key challenges
in computer vision.
And on the lower right, you see a classic
example where we take an image and
the computer will figure
out which object is what.
And try to find it also in
a database of existing objects.
So for example, we can say hey,
on the upper left there's an airplane.
On the lower left there's a human,
and maybe we can even so
some face recognition on that.
So these are all graphical
computer vision problems.
Tracking is another one.
So we wanna be able to predict
the path of the motion for
different types of objects in a scene.
So computer graphics,
I don't wanna talk too much about it.
We've learned a lot about teapots, and
bunnies, and
strange rooms with reflective objects.
Juan will talk a lot more about this, but
computer graphics is the science of taking
a mathematical description of light,
reflectant models of
geometry of the scene, and
computing an image of this that is ideally
indistinguishable from the real world.
Another emerging area is virtual reality,
and augmented reality of course, too.
It's an area that's been around for
a few decades already.
But in the last few years we've made so
much progress and we now have the consumer
electronic devices that deliver
really immersive experiences.
And virtual reality is being used for
many different applications,
from simulation and training,
to entertainment, to visualization.
But you shouldn't forget about
robotic surgery for example, too.
On the lower right, you see the da Vinci,
a minimally invasive
robotic surgery system.
Where a surgeon actually remotely
operates the robotic arm to be able to
do a surgery live, either in the same
room or even in a distant location.
And so that's virtual reality too
because the surgeon only relies on
the visual stream of the endoscope
that they see in the remote spot,
which is basically
a virtual reality display.
Fundamentally VR is the new medium that
enables totally unprecedented experiences.
And we still have to learn
how to use this medium and
create new types of
experiences effectively.
So it's a very exciting area of
a lot of dynamics and development.
Enhancing Virtual Reality is
also one of the grand challenges
of The National Academy of Engineering.
So not just from a content creation
side it's interesting, but
also from an engineering side.
This brings together computer vision,
display, human perception,
computer graphics, and
many other disciplines.
So you can see that's kind of
in this overview slide here.
There's just a HoloLens in the middle.
The HoloLens has so many different parts.
It has custom made chips such as CPU's,
GPU's, central processing units,
graphics processing units, but
also image processing units.
We have a whole array of sensors that
do scene understanding, hand tracking,
positional tracking, and other things.
We need to understand human perception and
it's limitation so
we can build effective displays.
And at the same time,
we need to create content, for example,
using things like cameras or
computer graphics.
So I just wanna spend one or two minutes
on telling you a little more about
our research area, or one of them,
to advance virtual reality display.
So normally a phone or
a small display inside a head
mounted display behind a lens.
And your eyes will look at
a magnified view of this image.
This will be simply bigger but
it also gets further away.
So each eye will basically look at
a different plane floating in space.
That's how we can think about it.
And that will be at a fixed distance.
So the focal distance of this display
is gonna be at one, fixed distance, and
that's not a natural viewing experience.
If you think about 3D vision.
And here's just a one-minute
overview of 3D human perception.
There are many different cues
that the human brain uses to
interpret depth from a scene.
So there's vergence,
that's the relative rotation of
your eyeballs in their sockets.
It's an oculomotor cue, so a muscular cue.
This is driven by binocular disparity,
the fact that we see two
different images with our eyes.
And this is easy to create with
virtual reality displays because we
simply render slightly different
perspectives in front of each eye.
But here's the challenge, the eye
also focuses it's crystalline lens.
And that's driven by retinal blur,
which is similar to a depth of
field effect in the SLR camera.
This is a cue that we can't easily
reproduce in virtual reality because
we cannot optically correct
this retinal blur cue easily.
All these cues are coupled together and
that's what creates a lot of trouble.
So in the real world as you
look at different objects,
your eyes will verge towards these
distances, so they will rotate.
But they will also accommodate, so
they will focus to these distances.
So all these cues are always
working in harmony together.
In virtual reality there's mismatch
between these cues, I'll try and
illustrate that here.
We can render images so
that you converge at arbitrary distances.
But the focus of your eyes will always
be linked to that floating plane,
the magnified image in space.
So this discrepancy between different cues
that the brain receives is something that
usually creates.
Eye stress, visual discomfort nausea and
other undesired effects.
So, our group does a lot of research in
trying to address this for example and
here is again an image of
the fixed focused to light
where we place a phone behind a fixed
distance of the lens, a couple of
simple ideas that we're addressing
that's focus issue would be to either
actuate the display by slightly displacing
it inside the head mounted display,
which changes the magnified
image distance.
Another way would be to use unconventional
objects that can dynamically
update the focal power of the lens,
and this is a very effective way to
change the magnified image distance and
accommodation of the human observer.
In practice, we need to use eye tracking
for our head monitor display so
we build a very simple prototype that you
can see here, which has a stereoscopic eye
tracker and a motor mounted to
the focus adjustment mechanisms of the.
Okay, so here's this prototype.
We can basically trace the motor
very quickly based on the tracked
eye position of the viewer.
And with only few millimeters of
mechanical statement we can actually
change the focus plan of
the display by a large amount of
the entire range of which you can focus.
So that's what you can learn about on
the overview of what virtual reality,
computer vision and imaging is all about.
These are graphics and all of these topics
including virtual reality this consist.
Photograph of the Stanford's EE 267 class.
So this class is focussed on helping
students to build the head-mounted display
from scratch over
the course of one quarter.
And with this I would like to hand over
to Ron who can tell you more about
special effects in computer graphics and
some other topics in visual computing.
>> Let me start before
you even get into it.
Just make sure there's
a reason that you and
I are talking about
a little bit more in depth.
The three topics we're talking about which
are the Hollywood Effects in a VR/AR.
If this is graphics traditionally,
there is a lot of small things going
on in graphics a lot of impact, but
there's been sort of modes of
graphics that everybody sees.
In your house, what people
typically see are movies and games,
those are two things.
So if you think about it and
look at all the movies and
all the tech that goes into that,
think of George Lucas, Star Wars, Pixar,
a lot of graphics was driven from that.
The other things are all
these video games.
If you look at the AR/VR that's sort
of the real time aspect of graphics
from the games continue to that direction
with not only the talk today, but
also his research program, and similarly
for the Hollywood special effects.
That's something that I've been
pushing forward for the last 20 years.
I'll talk about that in the beginning and
then where we're going next, and
that's also part of the reason that Gordon
and I are sort of running the center,
is we're sort of looking in the future
of graphics and where it's going.
It's important at home when
you're thinking about this,
like what you want to do
with visual computing.
That you realize there are these two big
driving technologies which are real-time
and not real-time, or movies and
games, in that sense.
And our research to talk,
everything represents that in some flavor,
but there's a lot more to look into later.
So I had this very general
Venn diagram to get started.
And it just shows the Hollywood
special effects now.
You're sort of mixing in
a lot of different things.
You've always had rendering and
graphics, geometry and
graphics, animation and graphics,
that's always been there.
And more recently,
physical simulation has come in.
That's something that has come in
the last 20 years and even more recently,
computer vision is playing
a much bigger role.
And in machine learning
we are going to as we go.
So, going back to my lab what we've
done for 20 years is critical simulation
you've seen it in many movies here
are some examples, Davie Jones,
Harry Porter etc, etc.
And when doing physical simulation for
movies what we focus on is many many
degrees of freedom, water, wrinkles and
and cloth waves underwater, smoke that
sought of thing and you really want
high visual fidelity, very rich details.
But what that comes from
is computational physics.
There's equations for the water.
There's models for the.
And so we look to all those things
in order to do the simulations.
But if you look into
computational physics,
what you find is that your algorithms are
really good for finding a drag on a wing.
Where the lift kind of wing or
modelling a scram jet engine and
vaporization of drops.
They're very very accurate or
faithful to real world data.
And it's not we want for graphics.
You want stuff which is sought
of hyper real in that fence.
So computation of physics
is a motivation for
what we do but it's not just taking the
equations from computational physics and
reimplementing them in
a graphics pipeline.
It's doing something different with them.
During last 20 years, I've put half of
my papers in computational physics, and
half of my papers in graphics in my 40
PhD students 30 former and 10 current.
It really struggled along with me,
to look back and
forth between those two different
areas and target simulations and
methodologies towards those areas and
it turns out, it's very, very different.
You can't pick up stuff from one and
put it in the other and vice versa and
that's been something that really helped
up lead the field in this area is
understanding what goes where.
You're like [INAUDIBLE] is that
an idea for computational physics or
an idea for graphics?
Yeah, if something in physics,
does it work in graphics or
does it not work in graphics,
and vice versa.
And that's been the essence
of my research program for
the entire 20 years that I've been in it,
is just differentiating carefully
between those two areas with each idea.
No round peg in the square
hole-type stuff.
You have to avoid that.
So more recently, say two years ago, I
started realizing there's a third area of
simulation which is very,
very different from what I had been doing.
And it took me a while to even
realize that even though I'd spent 20
years differentiating
the feature film technology from
the computational physics technology,
putting about 50 papers in each one.
But it started to sink in a little bit and
the idea was that if somebody went out and
filmed some or filmed the waves on
the ocean, and you want it to somehow
use those waves in your simulation
to get better looking water, or
water that looked like a lake,
or an ocean, or a bathtub, or
whatever it was, and use the data or
you scanned in some cloth.
You saw how it moved.
You wanted to use that.
Or, for human tissue, if you took a
bodybuilder, scanned in their muscles and
how they flex, then you can do a
simulation of biomechanics in the muscles.
You want to be faithful to that.
How would you actually do that?
I originally started out doing that with
what would be number two on this slide.
I took the computational physics approach
to be faithful to real world data.
I pushed into biomechanics for awhile,
and what they did there, but it turns
out the biomechanical stuff doesn't
really lend itself well to the data.
And so, it took a while but we start to
realize it's really is a third paradigm
for a physical simulation
which is popping up.
And just isn't true for computational
physics as far as like smoke water,
fire and human bodies, it's also true for
rendering in other areas.
Think of that not as just simple
simulation but just simulation in general.
Anytime you're synthesising
the real world,
you want to think about
different ways of doing it.
You're either trying to be faithful
to the real world, which would be
the computational physics or you're
trying to have something really cool,
like a game or a movie, that would be
the feature film type stuff on this slide.
Or you really want it to sort of have
the look and feel of the real data.
So, we start looking more
carefully into data statistics and
machine learning and
the first thing is data.
Data is what's really driving this.
There's more and more data everywhere.
Wherever you look, people are collecting
data, storing data in Internet,
pushing data around and as more and
more data start showing up, they get
better ways of collecting data and
the better ways you get of collecting
data, the more and more data you get.
Statistics and machine learning
are obviously the areas that work
with the data.
Actually, statistics, you would think
just the statisticians work with data,
that's been their job for a long time.
The thing is statisticians never had that
much data, so in theoretical statistics,
it was really a way to talking about
dealing with small amounts of data.
Even today, if you look at political
polls, they poll 1,000 people and
that's supposed to represent what tens or
hundreds of millions of people would do.
Well, why not poll 100,000 people,
or a million people?
That would be much better.
But statisticians worked very,
very hard at using tiny amounts of
data to represent large populations.
But the world's changing.
Now we have large amounts of data,
we can get a lot more data and
they're not really taking advantage
of it at the speed one would expect.
If you look at math departments,
going back historically.
Once computers start taking off, these
new mathematicians started showing up.
They weren't theoretical anymore,
they were applied mathematicians,
they were numerical analysts,
computational physics type people.
And it was sort of a new way of thinking
about the world through the computer,
as far as mathematics went, as opposed to
the way it was done through pencil and
paper in the past.
And once you had the computer,
you had things like numerical algebra,
numerical optimization,
numerical ODEs, and PDEs, and
new mathematics had to spring out of this.
Similarly, as we add all this data and
the statistics that they never had,
you're gonna need a new way
of dealing with statistics.
Then what's happened,
which is kind of neat from my
standpoint as a computer scientist,
is that people in my department,
Daphne Koller, Andrew Sebastian Thrun.
They sort of picked up the ball on this
and started taking all this data and
the computers and everything else In
developing this new area which we now
refer to as machine learning.
But machine learning people are really the
next generation of applied mathematicians.
They're coming out of statistics
departments because of the data similar to
the way the applied mathematicians come
out of the math departments because of
the computers, going back in the past.
So it's really drawn me
towards machine learning,
which is part the artificial
intelligence groups.
In fact on Tuesday, I formally
joined their AI lab at Stanford.
So the new part for me, that machine
learning people have been really knocking
the ball out of the part for
five, ten years now.
And the new part for me is looking at all
this stuff through the lens of physics,
because I do simulations.
And so when look to things similar
to physics as opposed to statistics,
things are a little bit different.
Here's a good example,
suppose I had ten balls.
And I took each ball and I dropped it
from shoulder height to the ground.
And I measured how long it
took to go to the ground and
I tried to measure
the acceleration due to gravity.
And suppose 9 balls fell with speed 9.8,
then 1 ball hovered in mid-air.
A statistician might say, well, okay,
it's about 9.6 gravity on average.
Or they might say, no, no, that one's
an outlier, let's get rid of it,
it's about 9.8.
A physicist might say, holy crap,
that ball's floating in mid-air,
what's going on?
[LAUGH] So it's a different way
of thinking about the data,
which is like looking at what's actually
happening with the physics as opposed
to just statistically kind of waving
your hands and saying it's noise,
it's outliers, this and that.
It's looking at the data
a little bit differently.
A good example is incompressibility.
For example, if I have a bunch of data and
it doesn't represent incompressible flow,
I know that data needs to go through
some filter to make it incompressible.
As opposed to just saying this
noise outlier is your other thing.
These are often called priors
in machine learning, and
many people use these priors.
But it's sort of an advantage that you
have if you come from physics to look at
it, and it's something we're
trying to do in our group.
So again, just to summarize
before I show you a few examples,
the goal of our research these days is,
and it's underline at the bottom,
is to design new numerical
algorithms to better allow for
the incorporation of data into
the simulations themselves.
Make things super real,
not just a cloth simulation for a movie,
which is really nice, but super real.
Pulled from real world cloth.
So some projects, the first project
that got us into it was face simulation.
And I've been at Stanford for 17 years,
full professor,
I've been here for a while.
So not a lot of things are really
over the top impressive.
I've seen all the impressive stuff for
17 years, and
you kind of get a little bit callous, or
a little bit more relaxed as time goes on.
But this idea really hit me.
It was the Wednesday after Thanksgiving.
And we had this idea for
muscle simulation for the faces.
And my grad student took the idea and
implemented it.
And by that evening, he showed me
a simulation with a face that was better
than anything that I'd ever seen before,
by a quantum leap.
And the big thing we did was we took
a bunch of data of faces moving around.
And we designed a simulation system
that could actually target that data.
So in the past when we did simulations,
you flexed muscles, you moved them around,
whatever.
They're biomechanically accurate,
physically accurate.
But what we did here is we learned
how to target the actual data, and
it really made a big difference.
In fact we already used it
in King Kong Skull Island.
We had the idea,
we wrote a paper in less than two months.
It was implemented in less than 12 hours,
paper in less than 2 months and
it went into movie production
literally right after that.
Then within less than one year we finished
an entire movie with it from idea
conception to completion, and it really
made a huge difference in the movie.
We've been building models for
a long time.
This is maybe a 15-year-old picture now of
one of my graduate students that we flew
up to Canada and covered in latex and
built some high resolution muscle models
using the old Matrix technology from
the Matrix films if you remember that.
These days it's easier, you can just
scan in a statue with the scanners.
We have much better
graphic technology now and
build a triangle face model out of that.
We outfit these with finite element
models, biomechanically accurate muscles,
everything you would imagine.
And we use cameras and computer vision
in order to track what faces do.
In the end then, you have some model for
how the face moves.
Typically using a lot of this you can
build an exterior shell model which is on
the left,
which is just triangles moving around.
But using some of our new technology,
you can take a skull and
put it inside that face on the left.
This is what the right picture is,
there's a skull underneath.
And put muscles underneath the skull and
flex all the muscles in order to try and
make the face deform in order
to match the thing on the left.
So on the left is just
a sculpt made by a modeler.
He just went in and used some animation
software to move around all the triangles,
get a really nice looking face.
On the right is a muscle simulation
which is supposed to mimic that,
and if you look at the two,
they're very similar, very similar.
But there's some small differences.
For example, look at the lips on the left.
They're a little bit washed out,
a little too smooth, and on the right,
they're a little more vivid.
And we captured that bit more vivid
because we used the simulation
stuff underneath.
I might say, okay it's a small change,
why does it even matter?
The reason it matters is the sculpt on
the left was supposed to be perfect.
An artist made this,
it was gold standard, and
it was something we used in
the FX industry as a perfect.
And then we ran one muscle simulation
on it one time just to check it out and
try to target that data.
And we were like, wow,
the lips could be better.
We actually don't have a perfect thing,
it's actually much improved.
One thing we struggle with in the effects
industry with humans is we make them more
and more real.
There's something called the uncanny
valley where all of a sudden if something
gets too real it's disturbing
if it's not completely real.
There's a gap there between things
getting better and getting all the way.
And so when you get to this gap,
you have to be very careful.
You typically pull back and make the halt
green or change things a little bit so
it feels less real, so you can accept it.
In fact, take a completely real human and
change it just a little bit, for
example, put it in a casket.
That's pretty scary, right?
Or a zombie, you think about,
that's kind of scary.
So these things which are almost real but
not real, they're very disturbing.
And they don't work well in movies, so
we're trying to get by
this uncanny valley.
If we knew what was wrong,
we'd just fix it.
This is an example of when
we know what's wrong.
The thing on the left we thought was
perfect, but it turns out the lips
could be better, we learned that from
the simulation, so we can make it better.
And this is the main thing we want to
address in the movie industry right now
using this technology,
which is can we make the faces real and
get through the uncanny
valley to the other side?
Here's a video that shows some of
the other benefits of this though.
In the upper left is a bunch
of sculpts done by an artist.
Just a triangle mesh moving around.
In the middle is the result of the muscle
simulation targeting in every frame
just like in the last slide.
In the far right,
you can see the skull and
some of the muscles moving around
underneath the middle to show what
the skull muscles had to do in
order to target the simulation.
What’s nice here is, if I take
the far left model which is a bunch
of triangles and I build a skull for
it on the far upper right in muscles,
and I can figure out how
to target the animation,
then I have some knowledge of how things
are moving which aren't just triangles.
So if I take that Yoda statue we scanned
in on the lower left and I fit a skull and
muscles to that, then I can take
the upper right skull and muscles and
map that one to one to the lower right
skull and muscles and move them around.
And I can use it to animate the scanned
in Yoda mesh without any artists' help or
any animation or any packages or anything.
It's literally just a muscle simulation
going forward, making Yoda do stuff.
Existing technology on the upper left,
map them to
the triangles on the lower left Yoda,
and try to push things around, but
since there's a fat lip on the guy in the
upper left compared to Yoda's very thin
lips, you'd actually see a fat lip moving
around on the Yoda, it wouldn't look good.
There's not a good one to one
correspondence between the facial
geometries of the Yoda and
the guy in the upper left.
But the muscles underneath have a fairly
good one to one correspondence,
because we're all actuating
things the same way.
And if I actuate a muscle or open my
jaw or smile or do something like that,
that looks different in every person.
But everybody's basically trying to
activate the muscles in the same way.
And so you get a nice one-to-one mapping.
It's much better than principle component
analysis or any of the other methods,
because it's more physically driven.
So another project I'm
gonna talk about is cloth.
This is one of our very big ones.
We've been doing cloth simulation
in the lab for a long time.
These are actually ten-year-old
pictures of cloth and
all the details we've
been able to collect.
Cloth's used a lot in movies.
Frozen's like a cartoon
example of using cloth,
and Yoda in Star Wars is a good example,
his robe, of a more realistic version.
The thing is, the real world has much,
much better cloth than
what we see in movies.
If I go into a movie theater and shut out
all the lights and turn on the sound and
tell you a story, and show you the cloth
on Yoda, you might say, that looks real.
That looks like real cloth to me.
But you also think Yoda is real.
And Yoda's not real obviously.
But somewhere during the movie where
it was dark with the lights out, and
you really wanted to
believe your suspension and
disbelief, you actually start
thinking Yoda was real.
So it's very easy for
me to make a pretty crummy piece
of cloth appear real to you too.
You want it to be real.
But you want Yoda to be real.
We have in the movie theater.
But if I go into e-commerce or something
and wanna do some cloth on your body,
you're not gonna wanna see something
that's supposedly real and
doesn't really fit.
You return it to the store
after you order it.
So there's really a gap between
the movie cloth where you're willing to
accept the cloth,
where you want the cloth to seem real.
And the cloth that you actually
would have in e-commerce,
to show how it's fitting on your body.
Something you could buy reliably online,
know how it's gonna fit, ship to your
house where it had to fit that way and
be happy with it and
not return it to the store.
So this is another place
where we wanna use this data.
We wanna take real world cloth,
scan it all in,
get all the data from how it looks.
How it folds, how it behaves, and
stuffed it into the simulations so
we can do simulations of it.
We can learn from it and have it
actually represent what would happen.
So you could scan a body model of
yourself, move your body around, have some
virtual cloth on you that moves and
folds and acts just like the real cloth.
Moreover, if I can actually mimic the real
world cloth and get the data into my
simulations, I can go back to Yoda and
make a robe on him which is so
super real that you couldn't
even make it in the real world.
And it behaves the way the real world does
but it's even better than the real world.
And that's what we really want in
the movies is something which is hyper
real and even better.
But if we can't do the real world cloth,
it's gonna be tough.
So what we're doing in the cloth right
now is it's the very early stages, but
we're already learning
a whole bunch about it.
For example, if you look at the figure on
the right here, if you have a curve and
the curve represents a scan of a real
world cloth, there's a lot of folds,
this is a black curve and I down
sample it to something I can simulate
on the computer which
would be the blue curve.
Notice that she has how
the distance gets shorter.
The lengths of the black line
between two of the blue points is
longer than the lengths of the blue lines,
I'm compressing all the edges.
And so if you build a database doing this
for machine learning or anything else,
you scan a bunch of clothe express it down
and make a function from the coarse cloth
to the fine cloth and then you simulate
your cloth, what's gonna happen is you're
simulating the coarse cloth and
you can't look up the fine cloth.
Let me explain that with
a projection of an example.
Look at the checkerboard on the far left.
If you have a piece of paper and
it's orthogonal to the camera, and
you project a square,
it's going to show up as a square.
But if you bend that thing away from the
camera, it's gonna stretch the square out.
So in order to make it actually
appear like a square on a camera,
as they do in this paper up in 2016, you
have to take the edges of the square and
compress if the paper is bent.
And so you have to learn how to compress
things when they're real length in
the projection.
I did a very good job with that so
we need to do the same thing in cloth.
If you look at the upper right here,
if the resh shape of the piece of cloth is
long and then you look at the line below
it and you compress it, it wrinkles,
that's what happens to real cloth.
And in our simulation, if we only have
one edge there, when we compress it, so
if you look at the third figure down the
simulation edge and when we compress it,
it just needs to shrink.
It can't bend,
because it's a single license,
we don't have the details actually
to bend it, but we want to be able
to take the real world data of the bending
and wiggling and project it onto there.
So we needed to actually shrink, so when
we project the wiggling back on there,
we get the right thing.
We can't just shrink the cloth by relaxing
all the springs by elements connect it,
cuz then it also stretches too much,
and so
what you really need is in set up forcing
edge length on your simulator cloth to be
equal to the ref length,
you need to constrain them so
they can't get bigger than the ref length
and sag like the lower right picture.
But you want them to shrink
left from their edge length,
because you want them to be compressing,
where you're gonna add the real-world
data from the wrinkles layer.
No cloth techniques do that, so
we had to go out and design a new,
numerical method for
simulating cloth, which allows for
edge lengths to be constrained with
an upper bound but no lower bound.
And so, if you look at the lower right,
that's an example of using
our new Inequality Cloth,
with inequality constraints.
And if you look at the left picture,
that's using the equality cloth and
what you can see is when it gets
really detailed in the folds there,
the equality cloth has much bigger folds,
some buckling, and
some resistance to the fine details and
wrinkles you'd normally expect.
Whereas, the equality cloth actually
starts doing the right thing.
They can start folding
a little bit better.
Again, it's subtle.
And there's no data here.
But it is in the real world,
you'd have many, many more wrinkles,
which would be superimposing
on this cloth.
And the cloth's already buckling doing the
wrong thing cuz you're enforcing the edge
length constraints to be equal.
Which is incorrect for
a compressed version of cloth,
then you get this picture on the left and
you can't put the data on it anyhow.
Think about it like you
have a sheet of paper and
you compress the paper a little bit and
you want to get some wrinkles.
Well, if you didn't compress the paper,
if it stayed it's normal size, just added
wrinkles to it, it'd magically be getting
longer, and adding geodesic distance.
And that's something you don't want.
You want the cloth
artificially gaining wrinkles.
And that's what everyone does now.
You take Equality Cloth and
add wrinkles to it, so
they're actually increasing its surface
area, which looks really bad and strange.
It's like your cloth is growing
wrinkles out of nowhere.
So, this is where a pipeline
is gonna look like for cloth.
Basically, if you start on the far right,
the fine result is scanned
in data from the real world.
Then you compress it,
which would be the blue bubble,
second from right, and
you get the coarse result.
Which are the compress cloths, and
those would be things you'd
store on the computer.
Now going to the far left,
if your inequality cloth simulations,
which will be sort of coarse.
And you look them up in your
database of course results, and
then use your machine learning functions
that you've learned or to find the fine
results from the real world that map to
that, and stuff those two things together.
The idea is you wanna hybridize
scanning of real world cloth
with the best simulations we
can do to get ultra-real cloth.
I wanna mention the bodies for
like one second here.
We're putting body,
mouth together with muscles.
We're scanning in weight lifters.
This is Michael Black's work from Europe.
We're scanning in people
to learn about the muscles.
We're trying to add muscles to the body,
because you want to really
learn how the body works under the cloth,
before you do the cloth on top.
The idea here is you scan in a really lean
body build where the muscles work first,
and then shrink the muscles
down to normal,
it adds that on top to
get a more normal person.
So trees are the last
topic I want to address.
And for trees,
a tree is really a multi-body system.
You can think of a tree as continuous,
with maybe the leaves as having
angles there, but as a tree bends and
moves around, you can think of
it as a bunch of cylinders.
So multi-body systems are commonly done,
we've done a lot of those in our lab.
For example, Davy Jones tentacles or
something, that we have done.
We can model tanks, and skeletons, and all
kinds of things, as multi-body systems.
The problem with a tree,
this tree in particular, which I
see on my way to Stanford every day on
my bike, is that that's a lot of bodies.
All those leaves, all those branches,
put a little cylinder for everything.
Not to mention that's not just a bunch
of cylinders, that's an amazing
configuration of geometry, but
I have to bend and move and deform.
It's impossible to do it with a multi-body
system that's way too complex.
We worked for a long time trying to
build something especially for that.
In fact we made this specialized approach
which would allow us to do something
really big.
Again, the idea was driven
from real world data.
We wanna actually take a tree model like
this, scan the tree in, build the tree,
simulate the tree, simulate the wind
hitting the tree and everything else.
We used the real world data to drive it,
so it looks ultra real.
So building a simulation system for
this was impossible, and
we had to do some
research just to do that.
The neat idea we had in that
research was people often and
all these robotic mechanisms,
build these approximations to the exact
solutions to multi-body problems.
We invert that a little bit.
We actually made an approximate problem,
and found the exact solution for
the approximate problem.
It's got similar errors in many ways,
but because it was an exact solution,
we could solve it without any of
the stiff issues in numerical OAEs.
We got rid of stiffness and
time steps to billing and everything else.
So we could actually simulate something
with many, many, many bodies.
The simulation was wrong.
it would never converge
to the right answer,
cuz we made approximations
in the equations themselves.
But if you go back to people who
approximate the exact equations,
they never get there either.
And so you can bound the errors,
that's not so bad.
We used this to simulate a whole
bunch of really detailed trees.
This shows you some geometries we
simulated, but we hated all these trees.
We used the best systems we
could to build these trees,
but we never were able to simulate them
to our liking because of the fact that we
just didn't like the geometry.
We really wanna simulate that tree,
and so we ran into a problem where we
couldn't synthesize in graphics the kind
of tree that we wanted to simulate,
we wanted real world data once again for
simulations.
And this time we're having trouble
getting the real world data.
So we went out and tried to use 3D
Computer vision to reconstruct the tree.
Fact we took drone and cameras and
flew them around a tree and
did all the usual stuff.
Then we started getting things, but
you know what, we couldn't get the tree.
We couldn't do it, and
what we realised was in computer vision,
a lot of what they do is use texture
to make up for missing geometry.
So when you look at something, you feel
like the three geometry is there, but
it's not really there.
In fact, when you look at this picture
there, you might say that's a decent look
of a 3D tree, but actually you're
not seeing a 3D tree at all.
What you are looking at is a slide which
is projected on your 2D computer screen.
It's completely 2D, there's no 3D
geometry in any of these pictures,
actually nothing I've showed
you has any 3D geometry.
You look at that tree,
there's no 3D geometry there.
You think you see something in 3D,
but you don't.
It's projected the 2D in your eyes, and
your brain are doing shape from shading
other algorithms that make that feel 3D.
And in fact,
whenever we do 3D reconstructions,
of things in your computer vision and
we think we're building 3D models,
we look at them on our computer screen.
So we don't really have a good evaluation.
So it turns out that we actually
need not just a new simulation
to incorporate the data,
we need new data for the simulations.
Typical computer vision doesn't really
construct the data that you need
in order to go through and
articulate the tree up and
build a multi value system
that can be simulated.
It's good for looking at, it's good for
placing furniture, it's good for
all these different things in a rough way.
But you want to simulate all this,
find out the stress and
strain on the floorboards from your
furniture and that sort of thing.
Or actually put a bunch of cylinders into
this tree and have it bend in the wind and
do its thing.
It takes a lot more detailed geometry,
even new computer vision and
machine learning algorithms in
order to just collect the data.
She found herself an interesting spot
where we actually need really high
fidelity geometry, the computer
vision really doesn't provide yet.
And so we need not only the new simulation
technology take care of the data, but
we need new ways of collecting
the data to provide to the simulation.
And so it's a two-way thing,
that's what led me more recently into
the artificial intelligence lab to work
with all these new applied mathematicians,
which we call machine learning people.
And the last slide just on wind inference,
it's one of the cool things you wanna do
with the tree once we can
actually build the model.
Once we can solve both
the problems I mentioned,
then you can actually build this tree and
simulate the tree.
And then video capture the tree, and
actually figure out how the wind
is affecting the tree and
pull that wind off and use it for
other trees or other models, or for
making movies and that sort thing.
So I'll wrap up there at 10:50 and
we'll have ten minutes of questions.
>> So we wanna head in to the Q&A,
as reminder please type your questions
into the Q&A box so that Gordon and
Ron can take your questions.
But we do have a couple
of questions to start.
So if you guys maybe wanna
take the first couple?
>> So first question is, what career skill
sets, education, training should we be
focusing on now in the future for
visual computing in a workplace?
One thing I wanna mention with graphics
and visual computing in general is that
people usually think of visual computing
as complementary to something else.
So you should take a bunch of
visual computing courses, take the ones
in certificate, that's why George and
I picked those,
is they give you a good basis.
But we always want people
to have something else.
And so, I talked about all the machine
learning and the data science and
that sort of thing.
It would be a nice thing to
mix a lot of this with that.
People also mix visual computing with
human computer interaction, HDI classes.
Where the hackers will mix visual
computing with systems type classes.
Graphics, just one of those things and
visual computing in general
is one of those things.
Where it's nice to mix them in
a hybrid way with other areas.
And so almost everyone who comes
to me says they wanna do graphics,
then what they wanna do it for, I always
tell them to add something else to it.
It's always typically the visual
certificate is the core.
But ask yourself, do I care about systems?
Do I care about HDI?
Do I care about hard works.
People make graphics cards,
that's part of graphics.
So architecture or something.
But find the other thing and once you
know the two things that you want, visual
computing plus Whatever the other thing
is, it will guide you through the visual
computing courses to choose the ones that
are most appropriate than hybridization.
Computational geometry, math.
Leo Guibas proves a bunch
of theorems all the time.
So if you take his classes,
you can get more into mathematics.
But that's my advice, is to always find
the other field you want in addition
to visual computing and hybridize them.
>> Okay, so the second question is,
will the technology improve better and
more accurate medical research after
this like cancer, diabetes and others?
>> So that's an interesting question.
Visual computing isn't necessarily linked
directly to research and medical imaging.
However, a lot of the techniques
that we're talking about in sensing,
in computational imaging, and
the applied mathematics and
imagery construction are also
being used in medical imaging.
We work very closely with faculties
from radiology department, for example,
that work on computer tomography,
that work on MRI scanning.
Throughout the medical imaging technique
use very similar principles and
very similar algorithms.
And even though I don't think
anybody of us is directly working
on cancer research,
a lot of the techniques may be able
to help discover new things
[COUGH] in those fields as well.
>> Okay, can you scroll up a little bit?
I'll take the geometric model one.
Is there an estimated timeline for
developing the next level geometric model
needed to address many of
the challenges explained today?
That's one question.
I'm also gonna take the question,
does your work involve cognition neural
networks, which is two down,
cuz I can answer those together.
Last quarter, in the spring, there were
two very interesting classes taught.
One by Leo Guibas on geometric modeling
using machine learning and networks.
And one by Fei-Fei Li and
her students on convolutional networks.
I actually took both those classes.
I mean, I know a lot of stuff
from reading and stuff.
But I listen to everything lecture anyhow,
in case there's something I was missing.
There's fantastic stuff happening right
now in the field of computer vision
on both 3D geometric modeling,
which is one of the big things that are
needed in accomplishing neural networks.
My favorite classes at Stanford that
aren't visual computing are Leo's class
I just mentioned,
Fei-Fei's class I just mentioned,
and Andrew Ng's 229
machine learning class.
So I think anyone interested in
visual computing with data or
anything else should definitely
make sure to do Andrew's class,
Fei-Fei's convolutional network class,
and Leo Guibas' geometry classes.
But that's really one of
the future areas that CVPR and
computer vision is that 3D geometry.
And Leo and I talked, in general,
about putting together
simulation in geometry and
how some of the stuff in geometry,
which isn't ready,
can be proved with simulation, and
some of simulations that present
ready can be improved with geometry.
So there's a real back and
forth between that.
Convolutional networks are really
finding a basis for things.
You have things like autoencoders or
what-not for a piece of cloth, let's say.
What is a good basis of representation for
that cloth?
You could try doing Fourier analysis and
finding sine waves of the folds.
Or you could do a convolutional network or
an auto-encode.
There's many ways of doing that.
But these are, I think,
two really big things importantly
related to the visual computing.
>> All right, I'll take a question
on how does visual imaging integrate
with images and
vision in neuroscience and deep learning?
>> So a lot of the classes we
teach actually draw students from
many different departments.
We have a big neuroscience
institute here at Stanford.
And a lot of these people actually take
our classes as well because even though
visual computing is mostly focused
on consumer electronics and
entertainment on areas like this.
Again, the underlying techniques,
the underlying algorithms for
processing images, for learning images,
for using deep learning convolutional
neural networks and things like that for
learning the fundamental building blocks
and the structures of the images and
what in fact is equally
applicable to other fields.
And although visual computing is not
focused directly on neuroscience, the same
techniques that we teach in our classes
are applicable to those areas as well.
Okay, there was a question on business
opportunities also further up.
Can you give us some applicability
to business scenarios beyond web
rendering of products?
So I think visual computing has a lot
of applications in many different fields
that you may not think of immediately.
I mean, what comes to mind?
This presentation is movie industry,
games, virtual reality,
things like that, consumer imaging.
But there's a lot more beyond that.
A lot of the students here at
Stanford actually go out and
found their own startup companies or
get involved with new and emerging trends.
And things like, think about virtual
reality as something in the analogue
to where the first phones came out and
people started writing apps for that.
So it's like a gold mine, almost,
where you can think of any
kind of an application, write an app,
and it can make a huge impact.
That's where we are now with virtual
reality, where people use it for
gaming
>> But
think about architectural walk-throughs or
virtual furniture placements or any kind
of problem that you may have at home.
You can use these techniques that
you're learning in these classes and
in visual computing to solve
some of these problems.
And that's what makes it very exciting.
>> Something else on that,
which is interesting.
So I have 30 former PhD students and
10 of them are doing machine learning.
10 of them are Google,
10 of them are in academia.
They're pretty split
up in different areas.
What do you hear back from
the ones who don't actually do as
much visual computing any more than
within other areas is that it's really
handy to be able to put a mockup together
of what you're doing with some graphics.
And one thing we focus on in some
introductory classes, like 148,
is just getting your hands
dirty with some open GL,
some rate tracing, learning to deal
with rendering geometry, and the basics.
And they find that for any project you're
doing, just the ability to do some
interesting computer graphics is useful
for them in their other projects.
And again, I cover the hybridization
of different areas.
And how we think of that you may end
up in the other area 90% of the time.
But if you can do graphics a little bit,
everyone you know is gonna want you
to throw things together for them.
And it's just a common theme that if
they think of you as a graphics person,
that you can just do better demos of
everything, and so keep that in mind, too.
It's really something to have
as a tool in your skill set for
anything that you wanna do.
>> So let's take two more questions and
then we're gonna wrap up,
just in the interest of time.
So what do we think about
some other questions here?
>> Okay, yeah, I'm gonna take a question.
How soon can we expect to AR,
like HoloLens and other things,
to substitute personal
computing effectively?
I think this is a great
area of research right now.
And we see a lot of transition
into useful products.
We see VR being used in gaming.
It's being shipped with PlayStation.
Microsoft announced that it's
gonna ship one with the Xbox and
then maybe other game consoles
where it's useful today.
Apple recently announced that the iOS 11
will include a lot of functionality for
augmented reality, but
that's gonna be mostly phone based.
I think AR, I just think about things that
are integrated in your eyeglasses and
gives you a display and then a window
to this digital world completely
replacing other computers, that's
still gonna be ten years out just so.
And that's a very active
area of research right now.
But I wouldn't expect this to
come in the next two years or so.
>> Okay, I think we're actually
gonna wrap up after that question.
I wanna give a big thank you to Gordon and
Ron both for
a wonderful presentation, and for
taking time to answer attendee questions.
As a reminder, the recording will
be made available within a week and
sent to participants.
We wanna thank you for
taking the time to attend today and
we will see you at the next webinar.
Thanks so much.